hello everyone welcome back to tree
house live here at e3 2017 I'm Matthew
joined here again by rich from tree
house and we have two special guests
today mr. Takahashi from monolith soft
and mr. Yokota from Nintendo in Japan
today Raymond is going to be
interpreting for us and we're here to
play Xenoblade Chronicles 2 sorry about
that set us up here rich what are we
looking at cool so if you've watched the
trailer you already got a bit of a taste
of what the world and the story looks
like so we're going to kind of go a
little bit deeper into the combat system
and talk about what makes the Xenoblade
Chronicles 2 special right now we're
looking at I'm going to do a little bit
of story stuff after admit and I'm going
to have mr. takahashi do some
explanations of the world as we're
playing but before we do this I want to
get into a bit of the combat so you can
get a sense of what's happening just you
know as I'm as I'm playing and as we're
talking right now we're looking at the
two sort of protagonists we're looking
at Rex on the right and Pyrrha
on the left it might look like I've got
two people in my party right now but
when I get into combat in just a moment
you will see let's take a look at them
real quick there's Rex
there's Pyrrha hi guys so once we get
into combat you'll see it's really only
Rex who's doing the fighting Rex is
what's called a driver and then Pyrrha
is his blade the blade imbues a
character with a weapon with an ability
to you to fight functionally so you can
see that he pulls out the aegis blade
and there I'm going to try to get better
camera angle on them you can see Pyrrha
is sort of powering him or charging him
up what this allows me to do is on the
right hand side you'll see the new arts
palette people who played the Xenoblade
Chronicles series or remember the arts
palette from previous games it's been
streamlined significantly now so it's
just using the four buttons on the right
hand side of the joy con controller as
with the previous in Xenoblade
Chronicles games attacks are automatic
and with every attack you'll see I'm
building up my arts you can see around
the little diamond I'm kind of building
up my attack power I now have all of
them fully charged and I can
in attack I'm going to launch my anchor
shot to pull some HP out because
honestly this first battle that I'm
doing right here is a little bit on the
tough side with just one person here so
I need to pull as much HP as I can
you'll notice my double spinning edge it
has a side attack bonus I'm going to try
to get around and demonstrate there you
see that little halo indicates that I
was able to get around and pull off the
side attack it's gonna be hard to get a
back attack on him oh he didn't turn her
off but every time I'm doing these
attacks as I'm doing my arts or as I'm
doing my basic kinetics I'm sorry I'm
charging my arts and then as I'm doing
my arts
I'm charging up my blades ability to
attack using her power that's the right
hand icon on my arts palette right there
you just saw it went to level 1 and I've
got this flammability pull back and you
can see Pyrrha is charging me up and I
just blasted him and now he's on fire
it'll be dead in just a moment so we'll
do some more combat stuff after that now
right now I'm just showing you what the
like absolute basics are about so that I
can start layering some additional
complexity on what you know it's a very
deep RPG and I want you guys to be able
to understand what I'm talking about
here as I'm going into this next battle
though I wanted to ask
Kakashi's not a question the first time
I heard the name of this game Xenoblade
Chronicles 2 my first question was why
is this Xenoblade Chronicles 2 and not a
follow-up to Xenoblade Chronicles X or
some other some other suffix Anoka I
know uh no title - ekitoku Xenoblade sue
you Titan and Eska arrow MacDonald on a
second coatt soon initialize anyway the
X no a No
siggi no height of the market on the
sofa so this is Nicole Kyle original
rate of chronic eczema by an open world
obeisance at Anzac main game why don't
you lock up you told Ellen Pareto one
meet sky martini on a story door even
not getting so majestic famous moody I
tap on a super classic leaked attitude
so you know when we were developing a
Xenoblade Chronicles X it's really a
game driven through exploration and in
an open world and with Xenoblade
Chronicles it was really story driven
and this time we want to create a story
driven narrative and game and so we
opted to go with Xenoblade Chronicles -
thanks that answers a lot of questions
because we do have a very strong
character focus in this game and we'll
be showcasing a few more of the
characters who make up your party in a
minute I do want to point out by the way
that where we are in development right
now there's still a lot of polish that's
going on so the graphics look really
great already you can see off in the
distance you can we'll talk a bit about
the world but you can see how much I
have to explore before this demo is over
right now but in the months that we have
left in development we're going to see a
lot of polish going on so bear that in
mind as we're playing right now I'm
looking out across this field and up
here you see the head of the Titan on
whose back we're riding over here you
can see the cloud see I want to point
out that one thing that makes this game
very different from other games is all
of the land masses are really Titans
you're walking on the backs of these
gigantic monsters this is the only place
you live you fly around on airships or
you ride on the backs of titans but
there's no landmass other than perhaps
you might be able to see a hint of the
world tree that was mentioned in the
trailer there but we'll be getting into
that a little bit later on
no Matt you had a question about this an
observation that you'd made when we were
talking yeah right so of course you see
the verticality there and you just
mentioned that these are Titans that
we're exploring right now and in the
original Xenoblade Chronicles game we
had two bodies of land bionis and
mechonis
and I kind of set up how you explored
that game and it really kind of drew out
the story as well I was learning for
xenoblade chronicles - how did you go
about building this world and how did
the titans play into it and on xenovia
the ones in Tokyo sing to you know poco
de animal story Cucuy hero Gotham on
this cocoon Kawada katachi dake wa know
on occasion juice you know a story in
Hakata cachaça sapucaia canary imam ali
Remo Connery story in Hong Kong cattle
at acoustic oh no arrows to you it's a
bachina
nasi lemak oconee it said mockingly
especially everything gets nanoscale
Domus Aurea estimate adapter you Jeremy
Tanaka - no I know
Arjuna sundry stress disorder Serena
Coco Emma die season cake annoyed :
Kodomo sets in India time toka a coyote
genome unit unit alguna
so you know some other vanity a concave
up you know not a discrete geometry so
the transaction as on the model unit
screen it happens and so you think I
think you will notice as you play this
game that these tines really play and
even more of a core role in the game and
the story itself and as you see here the
Titan you see here is kind of like this
giraffe like Titan walking on all fours
in the long neck but there are Titans
that are in humanoid form their Titans
that look like whale so there's all
different kinds of Titans and each of
those Titans have a specific type of
landscape that they have on their back
so like you see here those this one has
a lot of lush greenery and you'll see
other Titans may have a snow field other
ones are just water based so they all
play a different role and they all have
a very distinct existence within this
world and I think that you'll find it a
fun exploring and that's really a big
part of the story
awesome thank you very much now I've
been holding off on getting into more
combat because I want to show off
another element of the game
I mentioned that Kyra is Rex's blade but
actually have another blade with me here
food or and I'm going to conjure forth a
new blade earlier in the battle my very
first battle I picked up this core
crystal right here
I used this core crystal to pull out new
blades when I summon a new blade or
conjure a new blade into existence from
these core crystals they bring with them
a new weapon type and then I get access
to new arts and I'll talk a little bit
more about that too but I wanted to ask
mr. takahashi to explain a little bit
about the relationship between blades
and drivers and where that came from
I know must be a No Miwako destarte a
Tadashi a blade oh but did extend a
scarf oh no dude I'm Italian
no I don't can case it you know you can
stay honest itadakimasu Sherpa Monson
who later talked about it a McChrystal
tons of stones whatever I am tasty dry
mantle stitch cravat right way a battle
go criticisms and likeness yeah emma-san
in treaty Moscow more attack thank you
sheera
autocad economics no yeah Kurata Buddha
apres are not gue committed even put a
study robots could Victor you know game
same famous day come up again even
character ma concerning a new school for
a guy named Osama Dominus anatomica
coxinha Naruto's matamata bride emma sam
confession nom de correo came to me
ultimately given operation skin a pre
study there someday the ki netic so as
you saw in the menu option that you had
three different blades
you know the beans that came out of the
core crystal and as you explained
earlier which they these blades provide
power and strength to the driver that
they're connected with and as you see
haters there's only screens but there
are actually many different types of
plates and they all take many different
forms and they all take they all have
different attributes and skills that
they missed out on the driver and but
they all kind of separate into three
main categories which is attacker healer
and tank and so based on the type of
gameplay and playstyle that you have you
can mix and rearrange these Drive
drives excuse me I'm blades to really
fit your playstyle and it gives you a
lot of freedom into controlling how you
play the game and it's it's really and
there's a lot of fun to be had in
collecting and finding these blades as
well
I've just been slaughtering some
herbivores while we were talking there
but now that I've added a few extra
people into my party you'll see I've got
Nia and Tora here each of them with
their own supporting characters say
right now I have three blade to my
disposal just for rekt and I can swap
between them once they've charged up
adequately I did these people to my
party in part because taurah is a tank
that's what he's best at so I've got him
drawing aggro from five I got the field
armies kid is now angry at me too I
probably shouldn't have had that we can
see that he's getting our go because of
that red circle around them right yeah
so he's got all of that didn't look
great um he's got all of the aggression
of the enemy centred on him freeing me
up to move around into different
positions and pull off some of my side
and back attacks now the arts palette in
the past has been a fairly complicated
menu system to navigate what seems to be
the case in this game now is we've got
the arts palette of just a handful of
buttons on the right hand side but we've
also got the blades on the left hand
side when I swap between blades I can
bring out a new set of arts so instead
of having to navigate any menus I have
all of them on my fingertips I can just
have the blade that I want to bring into
battle which they're charging up right
now I may not I may kill this guy before
I get any blades in here let's see yeah
I'm going to swap over the squid or I
just brought him in he's got his axe he
comes out with all of his arts ready to
go and you'll see that I have some
special abilities that I can use for
different conditions as with the
previous Xenoblade games there's been
we've had like break and topple
conditions those conditions exist here
as well as a few new ones that can chain
together wrecks right now doesn't have
any I'll just go ahead and attack them
here Rex doesn't have any ability to
break or topple so I'm relying on my
other characters to do that for me and
they're not really they're not really
into it right now but we'll probably
knock this guy out and move on to a new
battle but I can chain off of my allies
attacks in order to trigger not just
break in topple combos but also blade
combos I'm sorry I can't resist wrapping
all of the money all the loot and these
couples that you're talking about it's
great that you have everything in your
fingertips it's literally two button
presses to get to any art so those
combos are kind of hard to set up and
they have to be time specifically so
it's great to have it so close at your
fingertips to get those off wait more
gentle herbivores come back here um just
Oh No you're so fast you're like a
gazelle bear Buki oh no he did it to
Choctaw AutoKey all soaking up this yeah
there's talking someone else yes I know
um if you have your weapon drawn out you
actually travel a little bit slower than
you would normally I was not gonna catch
that guy what despite someone else
evolution has been very good to them so
now I've got uh let's see Torres drawing
aggro Nia as a healer and so she's doing
her healing attacks she's actually
pulling HP for me oh there's a great I'm
not going to charge up food or in time
to take advantage of that break although
if there's a topple I may have a chance
I don't think we're gonna get durable
off of that now one thing I didn't get a
chance to talk about before that I he's
been launched someone else launched him
this is that what the launch was I think
it's a pass yeah I was going to show off
another of the abilities but we'll get
another opportunity in a second because
I wanted to talk about the blade art are
the oblate abilities right now Nia's
using one of her blade abilities poison
and you can or actually was toxin and
now she's poisoned
this Buffalo Gulu Gulu for you oh yeah
um thank you whoo I think it's new to
this but many people may have seen that
there's a lot of classic enemies from
the original games here like bonnets but
loo fo glue Pro aluminum Baloo Baloo foe
I'm gonna go with that for now
um but uh we'll keep attacking these
gentle creatures of the night and see
what see what attacks we can trigger one
thing I'm kind of holding off on for now
is I don't necessarily want to go into
the main field because there are going
to be some things that will kill me and
I'll show you getting killed inevitably
it's just going to happen right another
thing I want to talk about is my basic
attacks will trigger automatically of
course but unlike in previous games if
I'm moving they're not going to trigger
so I have to stop and think about where
I want to be in order to do my basic
attacks most about that is if you don't
want to move around all the time either
because each automatic attack is a
little bit different you have three
steps to that right one two three so you
can see that the basic attack is a combo
and I as I'm building up my arts I can
also trigger you see that little blue
ring was me triggering an art off of my
basic attack that helps me charge up a
little bit faster and they do a little
bit more damage I got it again right
there so even though some of the battle
may feel very automatic there are a lot
of real-time actions that you're taking
in order to build up your arts and to
build up your blade abilities as well I
have my flammability ready right now and
I might as well finish him off with it
oh he's already down yeah I'm sorry
Pyrrha that was nice um oh no I got
somebody else sorry you're just
collateral damage pal
and now you're gone I'm going to move
into some more challenging enemies the
Oasis where all of the gentle creatures
come for a nice dip of water is maybe
not the nicest place I could be so I'm
going to run past a little bit
more there was something else you had
yeah sure why you running around here
let me ask my gosh son in a lot of your
games you prefect the titles with Zeno
I was wondering just in general what
does the word Zeno mean to you success
at a table games no.2 uses obata yoko
squadron discontinuity focus on what is
going in your signature
hi Maddie no typos to Vegeta ena east
toka donut opacity Nina oh no no Cobra
Sudan coconut rotation chorus tell
chicken - Ray's original okay the second
attempt at facto Kumari achieve the
solid female model multiple each cake
with a dorama in arenas domino game novo
makoto's kumatora ena tomo texan any
penalty cycles give me stings so the
word Zeno really means like something
different or something kind of not not
familiar and I think in life when we're
living you know this you meet different
people and they have different
personalities different backgrounds and
it's the drama between the the the react
interaction between those people that
create the drama of life and I thought
that it would be great if I can drop
that drama into video games and that's
why I add Zeno to a lot of my games
alright awesome thank you very much now
I went over and attacked this much more
ferocious a series of Pharisees and
their pack animals so they started
calling in their buddies and so this
battles going on a lot longer now to a
little area of a fact attack see if I
can is anyone going to be able to topple
him no that's the real question I have
because I want to hang out here and see
if I can pull a topple combo out of this
it trips I did that a little bit early
but it was still all right now I've
triggered the chill effect you can see
the chill bars
slowly trickling down if I were to pull
off another Oh down he goes
if I had time to pull off another blade
art you would get a chance to see one of
those blade combos we will have an
opportunity to demonstrate that as we
get deeper into this level but for right
now to do you look big oh yeah yeah and
you're angry oh good I don't feel so bad
attacking aggressive animals one thing I
want to point out that's really
interesting about this take on the
Xenoblade the familiar elements is you
know played in the previous game for
example you had the ability to identify
how aggressive an enemy was and how they
would spot you you could see the little
eye to indicate that they had a visual
range or you would see whether they were
detecting you by sound and as I
mentioned more importantly you could
tell if they were aggressive enough to
attack you on sight you don't have that
in this game and it's because your
intended now to learn more about the
enemies Oh topple topple power Oh too
slow oh but this all right buddy
there we go we'll see if we can do it I
didn't get a chance to switch over to
food or in time to take advantage of
that topple but this time around you're
meant to study the animals you're meant
to study their behaviors and learn
through your experiences you might die
along the way I certainly will but I'll
just use this ability just keep firing
off abilities to charge up my specials
but you'll learn their behaviors and
you'll learn how to fight them through
experience and through repeated death
over and over again I'm going to trigger
torez shard ability now you can see it
charging through his support and doing
serious knock back shard is still in
play if I were to trigger with a
complementary ability again I would be
able to chain off of that now in order
to demonstrate some of that I am going
to start with grab some HBR
up but in order to demonstrate that I'm
going to have to head in the direction
of town so I can show you it's not just
fighting there's a fairly sizable town
on the back of this Titan now one thing
that we talked about earlier is the way
in which the setting shapes the lives of
the people in this world in this town I
wanted to ask Pakistan about the people
oh sorry that's just enemy yeah let's
just show you what that looks like
cuz oh I won it I didn't even get my
sword out in time all right humans
that's that's another one hit he is very
territorial and I've got nine months
I've got my party bar charged up a
little bit so I can bring Tora back oh
just in time to die oh now as I
mentioned before when you die I did I'm
in for this who knows uh we'll review it
on playback when you die you are set
back to your latest checkpoint you don't
really lose anything in the process
though so it's like it's it's
educational I just had a very
educational death right there but uh I
had a question for Kakashi son about the
lives of the people who live on the
backs of these Titans in all of these
different environments that form up the
or that form the world of xenoblade
chronicles to the noble angel no say
coyotes good in that type and I know it
touching you bassoon they do so touching
each seat is Johanna she came at
waterloo moes hi EEMA kobani are you
good at everybody TV I'm kidding eternal
yes no Pokemon so loco she sank a can
opener paso de locos I sang Numa kill
Hitachi State Department de coco de la
vara topo Monty's name on or cotechino
todo judge important day moco de música
de que nada
you know not even you still have some
questions yeah so Tabasco attends Beto
mucukunda type of taking on how to swing
up support a cristela to check goons in
Boca Samuel Azuka Gama check out this
early
Shizuku canary taxonomist sorezore
another sinister an opportunity consume
oh hey sorry sorry mama oh no hold on a
second naka de mi HTM you say don't kill
so creative engine what's it like on
things so as you see here this this
titan is called gamma and it's the
giraffe liked writing and as you see
there's a lot of lush greenery and
nature so lumber is a very booming
industry in this world and so once you
go into town you'll see that there's a
lot of humanoid characters people that
live there and they make a living out of
doing wood crafts and but if you go to
say a different Titan there are other
ones that are more militaristic in
nature and each Titan has a different
set of species that live there and have
a different lifestyle that they live
based off and this world is created with
a lot of diversity in terms of titans
and the species and the lifestyles that
that everybody has you can see there's a
bit of a lumber storage yard here I'm
Kopelman's alignment company the massive
toppled trees here one other thing I
want to point out you've probably
already noticed there's a day/night
cycle in the game we're just fighting
our way through a really rough evening
so there is a day/night cycle there are
weather cycles but because we're in this
sea of clouds basically this C also has
a tide and the clouds will rise and fall
and Evan flow with the passage of time
and that rising and falling will obscure
or give you access to different areas
within the world so there are places
that you'll be able to get to when the
tides are low that you can't access when
the tides are
it's another way in which the world
itself is informing the design of the
game and the look and feel of this world
another thing I really liked about the
very first game is when it went through
those day and night cycles it kind of
had the same theme music but it changed
a little bit depending on what it was
and that's back for this game I'm really
glad because I love the music in these
games so we're going to take a quick
walk through this town just so you can
get a sense of the scope of the world
the number of activities there are in
each place to do and also I want to show
you something over here again this is
very much a story of Rex and Pyrrha and
his allies very specifically and at this
point we are no longer there we are
we're wanted men we've got we've got mug
shots I don't know where they got those
mug shots and we've got a another driver
right here who's studying them he hasn't
noticed us yet I'm not yeah buddy
tonight ah a chance where's Tim oh it's
you
hey wait you're the guys from the
pictures um you'll notice he has his own
blade there as well and Torre's drawn
his agro so he doesn't even notice wheat
or I didn't even have his own mug shot
up there yet so he didn't he may not
even understand what this battles about
so direction I thought oh [ __ ] off the
master okay if I call you character he
must know an authoritative muscle you
need me dry part operating room
cognizant monsoon factor out oh and we
she I can move then you hiding or
something they he do not want to be
acted on it's getting challenges
pollution and you'll find that there's a
lot of unique and interesting characters
in this world and for example there's
there's a really powerful driver and a
blade that's locked up and if you decide
to challenge and obviously if you're
able to defeat the character then you
get great items back but you know it's a
lot of the fun and it can come from
discovering and getting to know these
characters and battling
them as well now one thing before I go
too far into the city I wanted to show
off you don't have direct control over
your other party members in a regular
combat but you can swap between them so
I just wanted to swap over to Nia who's
riding on the back of her blade it's a
very cat themed character you can see
her ears so you do have opportunities to
swap between the different characters
and I'm going to get into a battle over
here I mentioned that she's a healer I
just want to show you what that looks
like with her blade arts when you have a
Kotaku Bettina for total deaf court to
guarantee no danger this girl
Sonia's got a special blade where she's
actually able to ride him and it looks
great on the field as you're chasing
riding on the blade back through the
battlefield so fight a few more rabbits
I think just to you know thin the
population they grow like rabbits um so
you can see her arts are a little bit
different she's got a full heal art
that's super useful she also has an HP
potion art feel some more rabbits why
not
it's just that potion are works really
similar to Rex's art that we saw earlier
well the other healing art is more like
a standard what you would expect like a
healing one other thing that she has and
I'll try to charge it up during this
battle with this slightly tougher rabbit
is she can initiate the break status so
if I can trigger that break maybe by
building up my arts a little bit more
this rabbit might die before I get the
break but here I'll trigger the ability
you'll at least see the break happen and
then you see once I have triggered break
another character might trigger topple
and then another trigger or character
might trigger the launch status or other
types of status right so there's a lot
of depth in choosing how you're going to
attack and even choosing who your party
lead is going to be I do want to switch
back to Rex which means I'm going to be
dependent on my allies to trigger those
abilities for me let's swap blades
battlefield back to Pyrrha so I'm going
to run back through that town show you a
little of your architectures for your
little lives of the people but then
before I run out of time I do want to
take on the big bad at the end so I can
show off some of these more challenging
moments to do and I really really want
to demonstrate some of these combos have
been talking about because I mean I
serious let down if I tease it the whole
way through and they don't actually show
it there's a lot of going on in this
town
that's why I love about the towns of
these games though it feels alive and
there's a lot to do there's a lot going
on yeah just the ambient chatter of
people you can stop and talk to some of
the villagers much mostly when you get
them and build an understanding of the
world that you're in you got them gonna
run out here I'll just show off what I'm
up to look at this warship over and so
obviously you know as we work more on
the development will obviously be
fleshing out and expanding the town in
all the activities you can do in these
towns and cities oh that's awesome I'm
looking forward to that here's another
another Titan here I was actually
worried that they constructed a warship
into the body of this Titan you're
surrounded
well it's just you know it just seems
like he's got a lot of stuff on him um
but takahashi-san did reassure me that
he is still alive and still functioning
everybody my mother each of the better
security that I found this honestly she
must know I was legitimately worried
about this I'm sorry so I'm gonna that
is an enormous windmill let's take a
look at it where is that oh there it is
you know way off in the distance so
we're going to run off before I get into
this boss battle though there's a quick
fight with some soldiers again this is a
Titan very closely to the storyline this
the existence of this fort and the
existence of these soldiers here
takahashi-san would you mind speaking
about the soldiers that were about to
run across and their function here mama
korekara oh no oh no scent o Shahi
Mardan des Garcons so konna sukina no
story Johannes itadakimasu Judaism a
pony juice toe touches touch espero via
tiburtina No
guess I'd still be anonymous and anaemic
Onuaku retreat across any austero
dynasty anand Imam Hasan Minhaj
nakayoshi next a team to watch for
taking take on Kenya
they say madness so these soldiers here
are actually Imperial soldiers from a
different Titan and they've actually
come and invaded gamma and so the locals
aren't really happy about that and
they're kind of in a position where
they're kind of enemies of Rex and his
party as well and that's the kind of
setup that we have going on here we're
making short work of them though with
our party altogether
yeah is a their attack rod is all that's
left
wrote book made short short work of that
crew which is good because with the time
that we have left that might be enough
time to beat or be beaten by this
upcoming upcoming enemy inside of the
warship Oh am i doing it you're cut off
should we go oh yeah sorry let's rounds
macho Sankranti machine Buddhist in
high-tech I don't wanna grow a talk show
Panopto way now I also think one of the
great features about this game is that
even going into the airship is very
seamless there's no loading and transit
you just go right into it
yeah the airship itself is vast having
this this cargo room fighting it it's
got tremendous all right Coco missus a
little to none of this you know all we
can show this section but it really is
massive die by Oni you wish started to
send your boss difficult on machine to
mediate a curve and I hope you enjoy the
bathhouse
that we've selected to show here on
treehouse live it's a nice camera angles
on him he's gonna stomp us okay I want
to switch back to Pyrrha
I'm going to talk through my strategy a
little bit I'm going to switch back to
Pyrus so that I can charge on my arts
pull some HP and do some of the things
that I'm more used to doing yeah this is
sort of my standard starter strategy for
building up my arts building up my
blades abilities especially what I want
to do here is get all of my all of my
characters blades to
of their abilities charge up to
appropriate levels that I can trigger
the combos that I want so I'm not going
to use flame or toxin or shard right now
I will attack once I get to level 3 I
think that's the same is known I switch
over do I have time do I have time you
got any oh no captain all right I want
rich to get this combo so I'll talk a
little bit more about what we're trying
to accomplish here we have two combos
that we're trying to get done maybe one
is the driver combo which is what we are
about to attempt plan yeah I'll bore him
topple somebody topple him because I
might not happen out but it will happen
and the other one is the one that we
previously touched on the blade combo
which really makes these boss battles a
lot of fun and you have to think about
your strategy a lot if you want to get
them done either fast or even like
efficiently by driving or not but city
can no cocteau combo paste braid or
garnets except on dirty you should we
are you listening what are you horse
attacks little canary diamond C liner
and like you're saying that as you were
saying there's the blade combo and the
arts combo and arts combo usually is
really physical and damage whereas beta
combo has a little bit of a more
attribute elemental attribute to it that
makes the gameplay a lot more as you're
saying strategic and interesting yeah
you'll notice that Pyrrha is a fire
themed while food or here is
water-themed
and Ciaran my newest Oh your topple him
there is red large launched do the
launch love I love the visuals on that
one it's just hilarious to send them
flying and it does a ton of damage but
for my blade combo it isn't it isn't
food or that I want although if I can
get him toppled again I'm just gonna I'm
gonna go for the strong smash I'm at
level two if you look in the right hand
corner he's not toppled this time I'm at
level two on my arts but he's broken
again
no I'm trying to get up to level three
and to do that I am going to need to
keep using my arts even if they're not
necessarily the most appropriate art for
that moment got toxin we got chard we're
going to want kirim for this combo right
Bradley gray the chrome ball a little
bit more of a charge so let's switch
over to Kyra who's ready because I can
pull off some more so he get my arts
going I'm not going to worry too much
about trying to do the brakes and
topples right now cuz I really want to
do race my way to the level three art or
the level three Blaine ability and
something that people can look forward
to is the launch is not even the end of
the combo there's more after that so
yeah it's just sets the end of what we
have at our disposal right my gosh Tonto
and ready to go we got toppled okay I'm
ready to go and the switch over to kiram
so that all my blades are in place thank
you for the heads up on that I'm so
caught up in the battle so we're gonna
fire off with toxin first you'll see
that toxin hits did it hit are you
hitting you hit and now you look on the
right-hand side that bars going down
I've got to basically tree options that
can follow I'm going to hit virus next
which takes us to the next level on that
tree option and then I need to pay
attention here because there's a little
bit of action on my part when plague is
ready that virus is ticking down i
trigger blade i got three oh yeah all
right I think I might have done it did I
do it am i okay are we here oh wow my
comboing I think we're combo it looks a
lot of damage so you can see the amount
of strategies that you have to put into
building up those combos but when you do
it it's really satisfying all that it
feels so good and having pulled off that
combo I might actually have a little bit
more time than I'd expected on this yeah
yeah it's all nice I can kind of chill
out and relax and unwind get a cup of
tea switch back to Pyrrha
pull some HP because we are actually
starting to suffer just a little bit
he's cut Torah cornered it's gonna boxed
in
how do you know I'm there anybodys
alright more anymore
there it is so that's it with the
effective use of both my topple effect
and my blade arts we were able to hew
our way through him it'll just take a
few moments to walk back out let the
murk clear and walk into the cool night
air as we're taking one last walk
through the town
I want to know if there's anything else
that Kakashi son wanted gamers to know
about in anticipation of this title
yeah I know bustle toast if I know what
no because we didn't discuss a no game
on no meanness I'm feisty and guys Akana
this is what stage time on up in Wadi
Master Shuga high a concave imaginable a
go Soto you tied to the market
odenza Chronicles X Cara sanctioned a
little moons nos or mo a no chronic
reduce excellent okey no can't you're
not there's no system no imports could
pay illness net less no day on chronic
wrecks direct honest kappa tanzic we
also the arctica Sentosa director victor
Muto hey the new great one yet story you
okay Queenie Anatomy safety no that's
not you know certain kinda game a de
novo na mesquita table Jackson a Xmas
kena automaton commotion hammer I do
nothing say she some mythical so like we
saw we just saw xenoblade chronicles to
and so the past titles you know Blake
Chronicles X was you know compared to
that I think the development time we've
been able to develop it quickly but also
it was because we have the environment
set up after developing Chronicles X
that were able to do this and we're
building this game on top of the engine
that our system the
from Xenoblade Chronicles X and it has
all of the fun and joy of exploration
and a battle from Chronicles X but it
also has the joy and fun of the story
driven narrative that's in xenoblade
chronicles 1 so I really hope that fans
of both series will be able to really
enjoy it and have fun with this game
it's great thanks very much there's one
last note I wanted to make just in case
anybody had any curiosity or questions
about this if you've seen the trailer
you know that the game is voiced fully
in English we are playing an in
development build all of the English has
not been dropped into this build yet so
you're hearing a lot of Japanese
obviously that's not final but I felt
like I should you know Scott made
several yes let's shoot them did you
come not if it two weeks gonna have
Oliver and English voicing so so close
III just need to push out a little bit
just a little bit more but all right
well I think that about wraps up wrap it
up for us thank you everyone for joining
us to take a look at Xenoblade
Chronicles 2 and we'd like to thank our
special guests at Akash son and Yoko
tha's on up next we have Mario Luigi
superstar saga plus Bowser's minions so
stay tuned thanks very much thank you
thank you mmm stop
[Music]